monsieur laurent furst monsieur le
premier ministre
souvenez vous vous avez soutenu le
candidat hollande qui promettait de
réduire rapidement le déficit à 3% du
pib et d'arriver à l'équilibré
budgétaire en 2017
que de mots violents pour fustiger
l'action de vos prédécesseurs qui ont eu
à gérer la crise de 2008
que de belles promesses pour faire rêver
les français que de déception face à vos
renoncement malgré le matraquage fiscal
du début de mandat malgré les baisses
massives de dotations aux collectivités
malgré la baisse des taux d'intérêt qui
vous permet d'économiser sans effort 4
milliard par an malgré le produit des
contentieux fiscaux malgré les ventes de
biens immobiliers
vous n'avez à aucun moment réussi à
tenir les engagements pris devant la
commission européenne et plus grave
encore devant les français dans ce
contexte le gouvernement a annoncé que
le plan de 50 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur trois ans ne serait pas
tenue ce plan était lui-même déjà pleins
d'humour car ils escomptaient des
économies par rapport à l'augmentation
entre guillemets naturelle des dépenses
il faut dire que depuis que françois
hollande essaye de créer les conditions
d'une éventuelle candidature
les cadeaux se font nombreux
augmentations du point d'indicé
revalorisation du traitement des
enseignants intermittents du spectacle
baisse des impôts pour certains ménages
bien ciblées et cetera et cetera
bref si le père noël a les poches vides
hélas la hotte pleine de promesses des
promesses dont l'effet politique est
immédiat mais dans le coût sera porté
par vos successeurs sur le premier
ministre majorité désormais relative est
au pouvoir depuis près de cinq ans et la
modeste baisse du déficit budgétaire
fait de la france un des mauvais élèves
de l'europe
dans ce contexte les cadeaux de 2016 ne
doivent pas hypothéquer l'avenir du pays
dans ce contexte ne serait-il pas temps
de privilégier l'intérêt de la nation à
la démagogie électoraliste
la parole est à monsieur michel sapin
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics
ainsi monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
les questions sont que vous posez sont
sérieuses
pourquoi le faire avec grandiloquence et
en utilisant des termes qui par principe
cherche à dévaloriser l'action que nous
avons pu mener ça ne permet pas
d'avancer sur ce sujet là je vais vous
répondre sur trois plans premier plan
d'où venons nous en 2012 le déficit de
la france était supérieure à 5 pourtant
la crise vous avez frappé
elle avait frappé aussi l'allemagne de
la même manière le déficit en allemagne
en 2012 étaient 2 0%
nous nous avons à parcourir le chemin
que vous même n'avez pas été capable de
parcourir au cours des années
précédentes
deuxième chose monsieur le député
arrêtez de dire que nous ne respectons
pas nos engagements pris vis-à-vis de
nous-mêmes vous avez raison de le dire
et vis-à-vis des français est-ce qu'en
2015 nous avons tenu nos engagements la
réponse est oui
vous le savez et ça sert à rien de dire
bêtement non alors que les engagements
qui étaient les nôtres par rapport à la
commission ont même été meilleurs
amélioré par rapport à nos engagements
en 2016
aujourd'hui est ce que nous sommes en
train de vie aux engagements la réponse
est oui
il n'y a pas une personne sérieuse au
niveau européen au niveau international
pour le contester alors la question est
ce le troisième sujet que vous abordez
oui monsieur le député je le dis
clairement ici les dépenses des
ministères vont augmenter globalement
parce que nous considérons que
l'éducation nationale c'est une priorité
pas pour vous parce que nous considérons
que la pop de la protection des français
avec une augmentation du budget de la
défense
c'est une priorité pas pour vous parce
que nous pensons que pour la justice il
faut des crédits supplémentaires pas
pour vous et nous faisons en respectant
notre engagement de 2,7 pour cent de
déficit un échange avec parole est à mme
adam